hey this is presh talwalkar
you roll a fair dice until you get a six
what is the expected number of rolls
including the roll of six conditioned on
the event that all previous rolls were
even
numbers this problem is difficult even
for mathematicians
it was posted to gilcoli's blog
combinatorics and more which generally
covers graduate level mathematics
over a thousand people
guessed what the answer would be from a
list of possible answer choices
only about 18 percent got the correct
answer
furthermore
over 50 of this mathematically educated
audience guessed the same wrong answer
choice
the problem is quite counter-intuitive
i also want to mention one more point
whenever i make videos like this i get
comments and emails that dice is a
plural word and die is the correct
singular
the people who write these comments and
emails care about grammar
but they are not familiar with modern
usage of the word dice
according to the oxford english
dictionary historically dice is the
plural of dye
but in modern standard english dice is
both the singular and the plural
in this video i will be using dice as
the singular
with that context in mind can you figure
out this problem
give this puzzle a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for the
solution
before i get to the solution let me go
over the answer
it is 3 halves or 1.5 rolls
now the most common incorrect answer
choice was 3 rolls so why do people
think three was the correct answer
when you roll a dice there are six
possible outcomes
out of these one of them is a six
so the probability of getting six is
one-sixth
and you can calculate that the expected
number of rolls to a 6 will be the
reciprocal of that
which is 1 over 1 6 or 6.
in other words as the probability of
rolling 6 is 1 6 we expect that it'll
take 6 rolls to get a 6 on average
so what many people thought with this
puzzle
is that the probability of rolling a 6
when you have an even roll
will be 1 one-third there are three even
numbers two four and six and the
probability of rolling a six given that
it's even is one out of these three
possibilities
so they use the logic that the expected
number of rolls to a 6 given an even
roll would be the reciprocal of this
which is 1 over 1 3 and that would be 3
raws
but this is not the correct answer
because the puzzle is asking for a
slightly different question
it's asking for the expected number of
rolls to six
given that there are even rolls before
the six
this is a slightly different question
and i'm going to show you why the answer
is 1.5
so when you roll a dice there are six
possible outcomes
we need every single roll to be an even
number
and the first roll could be a two for
example
then we roll the dice again and we have
six possibilities and we need this again
to be an even number
so let's say it's a four
when we roll the dice again there's six
possibilities and let's say we get a six
now the sequence will terminate
we have a two four and six and that's it
so we'll be considering sequences of
this form
in other words we're rolling even
numbers which are twos and fours until
we roll a six
the sequence of roles we will be
considering will have the form
e comma e comma so on
until the role of six and in this case e
is equal to two or four
but what's special about six
imagine we rolled until we got a one
if we only had rolls of twos and fours
until we got a one
the sequence of rolls would be e e all
the way until one
and notice the sequence length would
have exactly the same distribution
because rolling until a six is exactly
the same as rolling until a one because
six and one occur with the same
probability
but then there's nothing special to the
role of one
we could also do the same thing until we
roll until a three if we have only twos
or fours until a sequence terminates in
a three this would have exactly the same
distribution as the other sequences of
rolling tier one or rolling to six and
the same thing for rolling until we have
a five
so what does this mean
is that we're looking at sequences where
we have twos or fours
until we roll any other number which
could be one three five or six
so the question is
what's the expected roles to x
or what's the expected length of this
sequence which i'll denote l
we can figure this out from a logical
consideration
if we roll
one three five or six in the very first
row
that's four out of six possibilities
then the length of the sequence will be
one
but
if we do not roll that that means we
rolled a two or a four in the first row
in that case we wasted one roll
and then we still expect to roll just as
many times until we end in a 1 3 5 or 6.
this is a memoryless distribution after
we have wasted the first roll we're
still going to expect a length of l
to get our sequence to terminate
so this will be the second half of the
expectation
so now we can substitute in the
probabilities that the first row
is x that'll be four out of six
possibilities
and the probability of the first role is
not x which will be two out of the six
possibilities which is two or four
so we now have an equation for l
we can solve this equation for l
and we'll end up getting that l is equal
to six fourths which simplifies to be
three halves or 1.5 rolls and that's the
correct answer
so if this explanation wasn't
satisfactory u i'm going to provide
another way that you can get the answer
we can directly calculate the
expectation using the definition of a
conditional expectation
so let's calculate the expected number
of rolls until a 6 given that there are
only roles of 2 and 4 before we roll to
the 6.
in this problem we can write the
conditional expectation as follows
we have the expected roles to 6 and we
have only 2 or 4 rolls for the n minus
one rolls until we get the six
and we're going to divide this
by the entire event where we only have
two or four rolls until we get a six in
sum roll either the first row the second
roll the third row and so on so i'll
first expand out the numerator into
summation form
and now let's calculate the denominator
we need to know the probability that we
get only twos and fours before we roll a
six in sum roll
this will be the sum from one to
infinity of the probability that we roll
six in roll k
times the probability we only get twos
or fours before roll k which will be the
rolls all the way up to k minus one
now the probability that we roll six in
any particular roll will be one sixth
and then the probability that we roll
only twos and fours up to that roll
will be
the probability two over six which
simplifies to be one third
all the way for each of the k minus one
rolls before we get the six
so now how do we calculate this infinite
series
we can write out several of the terms
and now we have a geometric sequence on
the right
this starts with the term 1 it has a
common ratio of 1 3 so we can calculate
its sum by the formula a divided by the
quantity 1 minus r
substituting in those terms
we get 1 divided by the quantity 1 minus
1 3 which will simplify and simplify
again
and now we can figure out that the
probability we only get 2 or 4 rolls
before we roll a 6 is equal to 1 4.
so this becomes the denominator
and now
we're dividing by 1 4
which will mean
that we're multiplying by 4.
we now have to figure out this summation
but we've already calculated some of
these probabilities
the probability that we roll a 6 on any
particular roll is 1 6
and the probability that we get 2 or 4
up to that roll
will again
be the product of 1 3 to the power of n
minus 1.
so now let's factor out the 1 6 from the
summation
and write out some of the terms of this
summation
so how do we figure out this sum
well it turns out this is kind of like a
geometric series but it's being
multiplied by increasing terms so it's
known as an arithmetico geometric series
and it is a common ratio of one-third
so because the common ratio is between
negative one and one it's a property of
arithmetico geometric series that it'll
converge
so i'm going to tell you the sum
converges and now i'm going to show you
how you can evaluate this sum s
it's going to be very similar to solving
a geometric series
we'll multiply the entire summation by
the common ratio of one third
if you look at what this will happen
term by term on the right hand side
we'll essentially shift over the
summation one term to the right
we can now subtract the second equation
from the first
and will cancel out
all of these terms
so we have the sum times two-thirds
which will be equal
to essentially one term of each of these
factors of one over three to the power
of something
so what we've done is we've turned our
arithmetico geometric series into a
standard geometric series this has a
common ratio of one-third and it starts
with one so we can use the formula for
the sum of a geometric series
we then simplify this formula
and then simplify again
and then we end up with s times two
thirds is equal to one
and now we take the reciprocal of two
thirds which ends up being three halves
so we figured out once again that this
expectation is equal to three halves or
one and a half rolls
did you figure out this counter
intuitive puzzle
thanks for watching
please subscribe to my channel i make
videos on math you can catch me on my
blog mind mindyourdecisions which you
can follow on facebook google plus and
patreon you can catch me on social media
at preshtalwalker and if you like this
video please check out my books there
are links in the video description